an unprecedented confrontation between
the u.s. and Iran on Iraqi soil for the
first time US airstrikes targeting bases
of an Iranian backed armed group killing
and injuring dozens the operation in
response to a series of rockets that
struck military bases where US personnel
are stationed a u.s. contractor was
killed in the most recent attacking
Kirkuk what we did was take a decisive
response that makes clear what President
Trump has said for months and months and
months which is that we will not stand
for the Islamic Republic of Iran to take
actions that put American men and women
in jeopardy a type Hezbollah is part of
the popular mobilization forces a
paramilitary group set up to fight ISIL
it's integrated into Iraq's Armed Forces
though the US has accused some factions
in the pmf of taking orders from Tehran
rather than Baghdad until recently the
US and the pmf fought side by side
against ISIL following isil's
territorial defeat two years ago the
u.s. retained around 5,000 troops in
country to support Iraqi security forces
as they search for isoh sleeper cells
hiding in deserts one of those clearing
operations coincided with the u.s.
mission against Qatar PEZ Bala the I
know acid airbase here in Western Anbar
province is an important launching pad
for operations against ISIL but recent
rocket attacks against bases where US
personnel are stationed including inal
acid airbase in early December could
hamper operations raising fears of a
proxy war between the u.s. and Iran on
Iraqi soil in an unusual announcement
following the inal acid attack the u.s.
publicly blamed Khattab Hezbollah the
Iraqi government hasn't attributed flame
but has tightened security that I'm near
departed I said the potential there
increased security measures were analyst
at air base in cooperation with
coalition forces there are surveillance
patrols and additional troops to secure
the outer perimeter of an al Assad to
protect the base investigations are
continuing until now but it's not
completed promises of investigations
have done little to reassure the u.s.
none of the government's probe
to any of the previous rocket attacks
have been published though analysts say
the details are well known I know hey I
think that the Iraqi joint operation
command and the Iraqi intelligence as
many details about the people who
attacked the k-1 base in Kirkuk the
Iraqi government was confused because
the pressure of Khattab Hezbollah is
deeply entrenched in the Iraqi
parliament in the Iraqi government and
that's why they decided to keep in line
with Iran and Iranian political parties
the Iraqi government divided and
weakened after three months of protests
demanding sweeping political change has
called on all sides to cease any
unilateral actions neither the u.s. nor
the pmf appeared to be listening both
have vowed to take action setting the
stage for further escalation Simona 14
al-jazeera Baghdad